more than 400 wildfires are now burning
in the Canadian province of Quebec fires
have been burning across the country for
weeks and the smoke is traveling south
triggering air quality alerts for people
in parts of the United States when New
York City's mayor has urged residents
with heart or breathing problems to
limit outdoor activities Rob mcelvey
reports
this is not what the Skies of New York
are supposed to look like the lady of
liberty holds her breath as the city
vies with New Delhi to be the world's
most polluted
visible from space the plume stretches
for more than one thousand kilometers
from Quebec's Eastern forests in Canada
to the Blue Ridge Mountains of Virginia
in the U.S it's prompted air quality
warnings for millions of people
over 50 percent of the US population
everything East of Columbus Ohio is
experiencing levels on the order of
150 to 180 which is an air quality index
suggesting that these are very hazardous
levels to be breathing
at the source of the smoke in Eastern
Canada the situation is even worse
in fact Canada's had its worst start to
a fire season on record with Nova Scotia
having its biggest fire on record and
the weather's not helping the
Persistence of this weather pattern has
meant the wind's been blowing in the
same direction four days and it's set to
do the same in fact it's bringing this
pool of smoke down across the eastern
U.S right down towards the Carolinas and
there's no immediate Improvement
Canada has already lost an area the size
of Belgium to fires this year a warmer
and drier than normal spring could lead
to its worst Wildfire season on record
Western United States has seen a
quadrupling of area Burns since the
1970s Canada has seen a doubling a
barrier Burns since the early 70s and
this is largely not solely but largely
attributed to human-caused climate
change a recent report from the UN warns
that an extraordinary increase in
devastating fires like these could lead
to what it calls a global Wildfire
crisis
Rob McElroy Al Jazeera
well Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau says Canada has been
experiencing more extreme weather events
in recent years
we need to continue to adjust and adapt
to what we're doing the the Canadian
integrated firefighting agency was
created back in 1982 it has seen many uh
improvements and and increases since but
we need to continue to make sure we are
doing everything possible to both keep
Canadians safe when these extreme
weather events hit but also make sure
we're doing everything we can to predict
protect and act ahead of more of these
events coming
well Kristen salumi joins us from New
York for more on the pollution situation
there and every time we speak to you it
looks like things have gotten worse and
worse I mean can you explain what it's
like there now and what sort of impact
this is having on not only the city but
the wider area
yeah the situation here has gone from
hazy to apocalyptic you can smell smoke
in the air here now and it's hard to
believe it's the middle of the day in
New York City based on how foggy and
cloudy only it's not fog it's smoke uh
the sky is the situation is not only
like that here but also up and down the
East Coast 12 States now including New
York have declared air quality alerts
and emergencies and they're advising
people to stay inside as much as
possible one doctor medical expert
described the situation outside if
you're exercising in weather like this
he said it's like smoking a cigarette
basically so there are warnings all up
and down the East Coast for people to
stay inside if possible school
activities have been canceled
outdoor activities have been canceled in
many states here in New York Washington
DC mayor Maryland graduations that were
supposed to be outside have been
canceled
and again people who have medical
conditions like respiratory issues heart
issues the elderly the very young are
particularly at risk so they're actually
being advised to wear masks if they go
outside
and you know you don't have to follow
the news to know something is wrong here
in New York people woke up saying that
they felt a little off that their throat
was scratchy their nose was stuffed up
and it's only getting worse as the day
goes on it certainly seems that way can
you just give us a quick update on the
situation in Canada what's the latest
with the fires and how long are they
expected to burn
yeah it's a great question I mean the
Fire season the Wildfire season in
Canada typically goes from April to
September but it doesn't typically have
this kind of impact so far away it's
particularly uh a bad situation in
Canada this year because of extreme
weather conditions there's been droughts
in areas not enough rain the
temperatures have been warmer than usual
so all of that is contributing to the
very volatile situation that could end
up being the worst Wildfire season on
record some are predicting and warning
it all depends on the weather and Dave
thank you so much that's Kristen salumi
for us in New York
we're going to go now to Matthew Adams
who is the director for the center of
urban environments at the University of
Toronto he joins us from Toronto thank
you very much for being on Al Jazeera
first of all can you just give us an
idea of just how bad these wildfires are
I mean it seems like Canada is having to
gear up for one of its worst seasons on
record
it's definitely looking like one of the
worst
um when you walk outside pretty much all
across Southern Ontario an area that
rarely experiences Wildfire smoke it
smells like you're standing at a
campfire it's just something we don't
typically experience in these major
Urban centers in this part of Canada and
it's not just those who are you know I
guess close to the fuzz there are
millions now being affected by the
smokers we heard from our correspondent
all the way down to New York I mean
that's obviously a major problem for
Canada as well though isn't it
yeah absolutely we had a major fire
issue in Halifax on our East Coast last
week and then we see it traveling across
really almost all of Canada is being
affected right now Canada does
experience regular wildfires throughout
the year much of that often happens in
the west coast Which is far less
populated these major Urban centers such
as Toronto rarely would experience this
sort of smoke and you know hundreds of
kilometers away the smoke feels like
you're at this campfire
can you just tell us a little bit about
some of the restrictions that are in
place in Canada and what sort of impact
that is having on the economy especially
for farmers
well it's going to be interesting to see
over the coming weeks how this settles
out but a lot of the restrictions right
now aren't really restrictions but more
advisories in Canada we're suggesting
people stay indoors if they do need to
go outside limit that time wearing a
mask farming I I can't comment too much
about farming right now and how it'll
affect agricultural processes but you
know just the general dryness and
drought conditions are not positive for
agriculture as it is already no the
White House has just come out and
basically explicitly said that this is
due to climate change saying that the
wildfires are an alarming example of
climate change and we heard Justin
Trudeau uh a little earlier sort of
allude to the the extreme weather that
Canada is facing is that the feeling in
Canada as well that this is a direct
result of climate change
I think for the average citizen this is
probably one of their first experiences
of major climatic impacts the fire
scientists in Canada have been saying
this for the last few decades that
climate change will result in these
major fires and now we're starting to
see those effects much of Canada I think
has been insulated from a lot of the
climate change impacts but now we are
seeing it on the ground in our major
Urban centers
okay thank you so much for your time and
your Insight that is Matthew Adams
director for the center of urban
environments at the University of
Toronto thank you
thank you